(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] To date,
scientists have found
over 925,000 species of insects.
And there is one man still
determined to find more.
(triumphant orchestral music)
Meet Dr. Isaí.
He is an entomologist,
but he doesn't always work
in your typical lab.
- [Isaí] That's right.
- [Narrator] He tracks to
the Patagonian ice fields
searching for new insect
species that have been hiding
for over 200 million years.
- [Isaí] Due to the frigid and
drastically changing climate,
there is very little
information on the insects
that inhabit the area.
Every day is different for me.
I'm looking for creatures
smaller than my pinky nail,
so I'm always searching
for the tiniest indication
of any insect life.
- [Narrator] This year, Isaí stumbled upon
a new pool of water among the vegetation.
- [Isaí] It's there that I found something
that I've never seen before.
The coloration on the bottom of the insect
varying from other species.
- [Narrator] Isaí took
the insect back to his lab
and ended up making history.
- [Isaí] Discovering this new species
was the most amazing thing.
It felt as though all of
my hard work had paid off.
I couldn't wait to share it
with the rest of the world.
- [Narrator] This only
motivated Isaí further.
But in order to be successful
in his search for new species,
he's needed some other unexpected skills.
Sometimes, I feel like
I'm an extreme athlete.
I usually carry over 80 pounds on my back.
I take my microscopes, my cameras, vials
and anything else I might need
to document these expeditions.
- [Narrator] It's also
extremely important to Isaí
that he's able to get to each new location
with a low carbon footprint.
- [Isaí] I always manage to
bike, hike, swim or raft.
- [Narrator] But climate
change and shifting conditions
can also make his work
extremely dangerous.
- [Isaí] Melting glaciers
can sometimes cause
an outburst flood, which could
be fatal if I'm not prepared.
And if I'm not wearing my protective gear,
my skin could burn just
from being exposed to the
freezing water for more than 10 seconds.
- [Narrator] Isaí feels it
is not only his mission,
but his responsibility
to continue this work.
With more than 40 possible
species under review,
Isaí has no plans of slowing down.
- [Isaí] I'm working against the clock
because the homes of these
insects are rapidly disappearing
due to climate change and human impact.
I hope to continue studying
them and to discover their
hidden worlds before our
biodiversity is changed forever.
(music)